[Music]
june 18th pikes peak center colorado
springs colorado prepares
for the funniest
show
on earth
hold on i'm uh
i'm gonna pull a u-e
that's how i say u-turn u-e
hey huey
so you think that guy's gonna tell on us
ewey
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
strangers
[Music]
hmm
that's the sound of monday yeah yeah i
mean it's the sound of every day
pretty much yeah yeah that's true but
you haven't been with us over the
weekend which i should let you know
because we're going to be talking about
monkey bach monkey box
monkey boxing i'm sure it happened
somewhere in thailand of course no no
you box him go uppercut hook left right
not where my mind went and the monkey
pox which is hint
right now primarily i'm fine with my
games so uh if we are not on youtube of
course you can watch this stream on
rumble monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern and we have an additional
45 minutes to an hour every day on mug
club monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern we never know when we get
removed from youtube it's just like a
surprise
that's smiling at me in my inbox
that's what you want to say so we will
be talking about monkey pox today
everything you need to know uh first off
you don't most of you right now don't
really need to worry about it what you
need to worry about is the media lying
you need to worry about the cdc lying
you need to worry about
former vice president joe biden being
[ __ ] those are the primary concerns
but i will say this
if you haven't taken part
in any how should i say this and if you
have kids i should warn you that we're
going to be discussing the realities of
monkey pox today so it's probably not
age-appropriate so three
two
if you haven't been attending
uh
fetish gay orgies in brussels where
you're raw dogging strange somali
pirates you're probably fine excuse me i
have to go to the doctor yes
well the problem is his his pirate is a
somali doctor ah wow
fox belong to mine now your parks belong
to me
so uh we're gonna be talking about that
we're gonna be talking about taiwan
which is a big deal you know we've done
i recommend that you go watch this
segment that we did a long time ago on
what a war between china and taiwan
would look like and what the united
states needs to do again your primary
concern here is that former vice
president joe biden has been saying
things that don't match up with other
things that don't match up with the the
state department and none of it makes
sense and again the concern is
you know primarily mental retardation so
my question to you for the day is would
you rather get monkey pox
or spend a weekend with kamala harris
so monkey pucks are herpes
guessing
allegedly allegedly well yeah half the
city council possibly monkey pucks or
monkey pucks and herpes
mr mayor willie brown can we ask you
about the city council herpes epidemic i
have no idea
why do you keep holding in your lip and
covering your mouth when you talk all
right i'm excited
anybody got a breva all right you kissed
my baby i don't know no let's not do
that
baby just turns around looking like like
the elephant man
all right before we move on with all
that gerald a is here glad to have you
with us how are you sir i am well sir
how are you okay i have a little bit of
a scratchy throat yeah um i don't think
it's monkey pox because i haven't been
uh
how are you yeah
you know i was better until i screwed up
the connection with the blaze that's why
we started that's why we started late
yeah it wasn't youtube i kicked it right
here because you made me angry and i
know that i need to learn how to deal
with my anger yeah and it's like you
know suck yeah it's not that you won't
like him when he's angry he's just very
annoying when he's angry
he's catty he's big he's [ __ ] he's
monkey pox carrier-like yes how dare you
and then you uh know him you see him you
love him you can hear him you can follow
him on twitter at landau dave the
quickest wit in the west the quickest
man in his feet and we're going to be on
tour here in colorado springs is it june
18th june 18th but a lot of squad.com
tour there are uh i think like a couple
hundred tickets left in the it's
effectively a morning show because we
couldn't get the venue late feels like
it yeah how are you ahoy good how about
you i was laying you up for ahoy ahoy no
monkey pox not at the moment i thought
we had a vaccine against monkey pox
against smallpox oh but not against
monkey power no it works oh cause i
thought i've been vaccinated uh you may
have
yeah again it's not really a concern for
you or for me unless they're lying this
is the thing it could well we'll get to
it it could be mutated right you know
and and that's one of those things where
we don't know if the cdc is lying or
biden is lying because they're not
saying the same thing or both who knows
or both could be third option i don't
know i think we need to do like we need
to interrogate all of the people who
were at that gay fetish festival like
the next 48. stephen it's just a
festival is this chickenpox i don't
understand yeah you see the next 48
where they always interrogate people
you know just as i'm like hey twink dog
did you see uh uh lube bear yesterday
like i don't know nothing about lou bear
why are you covering monkey box i mean
we hung out once
my penis is now ribbed yes what's wrong
with pox
chicken
i got i got i don't have i got two pocks
all right let's go
to uh this before that because we want a
little bit of levity although there'll
be plenty of levy with monkey pockets
let's be honest we're mostly fine
this uh this guy here oh i always love
this you know they canceled cops so we
bring it to you this guy almost got away
with vandalizing a cop car
and by almost i mean not at all
[Music]
and then he gets watched pepper sprayed
oh man
that's the problem with pepper spray is
uh
black guys can run faster than fat white
cops
yes
but here's the thing
when you do too many drugs
it is blinding
i love how he could have very easily
recovered
but gave up
this
it's like ah ah damn ah
ah screw it i'll stay here why didn't
you show alfonso roberto giving him the
10 grand yes
oh that's awesome
you imagine being in what are you in for
oh you're the guy you hit the pole hey
guys you hit the you hit the po lease
then you hit the pole the houser's like
we got him yeah like kinda kinda
like he ran into a pole i chased him
down we have video video footage well a
poll with him hey hey hey carl it's the
guy who hit that yeah the one who hit
her like the flintstones like dawg that
[ __ ] he's right here
that's not the only point
jail i heard you like poles that's it
that's right
also pepper spray we got some spicy
legend kings
i like to stab yeah that's what i'm
saying
why would you try to
vandalize a cop car in broad daylight
like they're not nearby i have another
crowded area
oh i'm sorry that's just wonderful i
mean he's probably talking trash as he's
running away yeah i got you bowed yeah
you gotta pick your moment though that's
not your time to shine no i'm surprised
but again i'm surprised he didn't get up
no and run away because you would think
him committing that crime it's so stupid
that he would have to be on some
mind-altering substance like pcp or
something that that would allow him to
recover very quickly so i can't make
heads or tails of it all i know is it's
a feel-good story of the year it really
is yes justice was served yes although
those cops need to do some they need to
do something cardiovascular let's go
guys i mean
they didn't even what was that 30 yards
yeah the guy just gives up he's like
eight steps in and he's like just go
this is yeah he's like the detroit lions
defense they're like ah he's two feet
ahead of me i'll let him go we all know
we're not gonna win uh we're insured
yeah i'm not pulling a hammy for that
guy
i don't give a rat's ass they've
defunded us as it is i don't you know
whatever it's the shoe we don't have the
insoles anymore
my knees are bad could have gone pro yep
uh it's not worth the bunion damage
gonna go back i need a knife when i get
to the corns all right
this is something that's new to uh well
not new maybe new to you guys but
twitter but uh it's near and dear to
dave dave's heart night again we'll be
in colorado springs june 18th
and dave had some shows coming up this
weekend you can see all them uh
littlesquare.com we have a big fall tour
we'll be announcing too so you know
comedians being attacked on stage is
kind of a big thing physically
but even more than that is just
comedians now there's this constant fear
of performing and fear of backlash and
and they have to take all these measures
of making sure that people aren't taking
video and taking pictures or you know
shooting them
so uh john mullaney this has been
happening now he's under fire because
his and this is a quote from on on on
twitter his trans fans felt ambushed ah
we're not talking about uh the brussels
festival no when dave chappelle went on
stage uh as one of the opening acts and
he ate a drop in set yes he came in
because he lives near columbus ohio and
right
you know
yellow springs right and popped in and
gave them extra comedy right and so
people were mad
about free comedy from one of the
greatest comedians of all time because
they claimed that you know he made uh he
made jokes
about trans people and they were like we
didn't we if we'd have known we would
have never would have come we came to
see john mullaney not to be assaulted so
the claim from one audience
remember was that the opening joke was
grotesquely transphobic
he made a joke about when he was
attacked how the guy had a knife that
looks like a gun
or the other way around he said that
maybe it was the knife that identified
as a gun okay so firstly that's a
perfect joke yes
i'm surprised that people are offended
at that in other words if you can't joke
about a gun identifying as a knife or a
knife identifying as a gun you can never
make jokes about the trans community at
all period that's as harmless of a joke
as you can possibly get and by the way
he's joking about someone who tried to
stab him
correct tried to murder him with a knife
but hang on now it was a knife jammed
into a plastic gun we don't know how the
knife our gun did identify that's true i
i smell intolerance all hail rudy well
you're right
rudy except the rudy thing
what's that i guess uh
i guess the uh
you're you're telling me the gun slash
knife released a statement yes oh uh
okay well i'll read it it says uh i
shouldn't have taken part in the
attempted murder of dave chappelle
praise allah la county didn't press
charges
the worst crime here is being
misgendered i was born a knife but my
whole life struggled and felt like a gun
that's why i was wearing the skin of a
firearm calling me a knife or gun slash
knife is weapons phobic i identify as a
gun that is who
i
am wow
do you have egg on your face i think
apology is in order i would think so
dave okay uh
all right
i'm sorry i didn't mean to hurt any
feelings um
that person clearly meant to stab
dave chappelle with a gun
better much better
yeah that makes sense the people of john
melanie paid for comedy and they were
upset that they got comedy that's the
story folks i get that i once ordered a
burger and got a burger it was
dehumanizing and that is when i began
cutting myself yeah you know say i i had
uh i don't talk about a whole lot but a
tragic thing happened when um i ordered
a pizza one time and they brought me
pizza yeah did you start by paper cuts
on your inner thighs uh it was more it
was forearms and it's just so i can feel
something i understand i also started
cutting the pizza um because i didn't do
a good job with the slicer that's true i
don't know if it was a slicer could have
been a gun shaped like a slicer yeah you
don't know
i hate all of you right now but the only
thing i would like to do is cut to the
chase admonish him he's not having fun
come on all right admonish him
to the chase i say we kill him
look look here's one thing too people
this is circulating i want to be clear
about this we'll probably bring it back
on mud club uh there's a circulating
clip of george carlin where people
saying how if you want to know what
george carlin would say and he's talking
about andrew dice clay saying you know i
feel like he's uh targeting the
marginalized immigrants women blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah okay far be it
for me to defend androidized clay here's
the thing i get that the idea here with
comedy is you are supposed to attack
those
in positions of authority you don't want
to punch down i think that i think that
that all targets right are within the
limits except for the helpless so for
example someone who is literally
mentally disabled specifically or unable
to defend themselves it just doesn't
necessarily go over well but i'm not
going to complain if somebody does it so
everything is fair game except for the
helpless but if you want to talk about
punching up look look are we actually
going to act as though the
lgbtqaaiplus bully pulpit is not in a
pro
in a position of wheeling
disproportionate power yeah you want you
want to know
how
we know that they are look at any other
stand-up special or any netflix show
that exists and it constantly [ __ ]
about patriarchy in the white male and
the very fact that dave chappelle made a
joke about a knife identifying as a gun
and it becoming a controversy tells you
that this isn't punching down well yeah
but him almost being murdered and what
people yeah it's failed to see is at the
time dice was punching down to the
marginalized that's true and nowadays
that's punching up right they are this
is the only time where the people that
have the most power claim to be victims
right that's this is the only time it
seems in history well and of that
alphabet soup that you just listed the
teas are definitely in charge yes right
they have there's almost no other group
right now being talked about even the
gay pride parades and festivals are
headed by t's most of the time right so
it's like nary a g to be found well also
if you're going to go in order of you
know percentage it should be glbt but of
course it's always ladies first and so
they get right up there and they're like
oh wait munch carpet it's like fine lgbt
good i think we just dropped the bee i
mean it seems redundant i think we just
dropped all the l's off at the lesbos
island
it's an island named after that or bass
pro well you know they have a they have
a steakhouse in there or something about
ll
lipstick oh i thought we were talking
about that or cool jj deep blue c
cool j you ate my bird
q
i don't know what's happening speaking
of bush
let's move on to monkey pox and i do
have a question for you
how much do you know about monkey pox
obviously right now it's sort of
circulating in the media and i know that
a lot of people are feeling
as though it could be a repeat of the
kovid right where people are saying oh
no they're starting to stir up some kind
of concern here as we go into an
election because it doesn't seem like
the riots really work they didn't last
very long right this is you really
notice a pattern of sowing division this
is what happens from the left as they go
into an election whereas what happens is
they blame the right of sowing division
after an election
yeah after they've sown division right
exactly that's usually what happens so
um you know you think about it it was
like black lives matter riot burned down
cities they shouldn't stop rioting as
kamala harris said right and then you
see the terrorists on the right who are
saying
a second you can't go against the state
constitution and just allow mass uh
unrequested mail-in ballots like this i
don't know which one i see i think we
can see who the bad guys are here oh
it's not the guys burning down walgreens
and shooting cops
no no that's different i'm so i just i
get so confused they don't identify as
violent no they don't
they don't identify as identification
it's peaceful and so do
so does the media yeah and their fires
identify as cold yes
a cold front if you will yes exactly yes
that happens inside of shops that's like
heat mizer putting on jack frost makeup
yeah i am a mostly peaceful fire steven
he's mr heath nicer okay monkey pox yes
monkey pox all right first let me tell
you you probably don't need to worry
based on what we know about monkey pox
historically but there could be some
information they're not telling you so i
want to get to uh
everything this is going to be a little
bit nerdy here so first monkey pox is
here
we roll we rolled out the uh we rolled
out the rainbow carpet and joe biden
said that everybody
should be concerned about it
good question one of your health
advisors told you your level of concern
should be about monkey [ __ ] and the
cases that are in the united states and
around the world well they haven't told
me the level of exposure yet but it is
something that everybody should be
concerned about everybody should be
concerned about
figure out what we do
what uh
okay
remember when bill murray and scrooge
has his boss come back and the mouse
crawls out of the back yes
i don't mind if you shoot me but go easy
on the bacardi exactly
the hair's the same i know
it is exactly someone bring that up from
scrooge we'll have it on mud club the
rat crawls out with the golf ball okay
so he says everybody should be concerned
about it as of may 21st 92 cases have
been confirmed
28 suspected cases globally under
investigation in the u.s it's like one
to five cases yeah so not a whole lot
yet no the end days are upon us
just in time for june look behind you
there's the horseman yes there's the
monkey-pocked gay horseman
now let me be clear about this and it's
in it's not and if you have kids they
shouldn't watch this segment so comment
below too i would really did you know
about the gay thing with monkey pox
because it took me a long while i was
like one of the monkey bugs i know the
gay thing
looked all around on youtube i can't
find the gay thing
and then i realized okay this is the gay
thing so the current outbreak uh it is
it's spreading in in a new way from how
monkey pox has before
the gay community i want to be careful
just the g seems to be at uh an elevated
risk
so the uk health security agency
epidemiologist uh mateo prashaka
know how to pronounce it said
the high proportion of cases in the
current outbreak in england that are gay
or bisexual you can bring us up there uh
kevin uh gay or bisexuals highly
suggestive of spread in sexual networks
sexual networks yeah i would say so what
is that if it's 60
are gay when they make a certain
percentage of the population et
television yes
[Laughter]
you guys have net worth it's just
pornography oh right yeah
what do you think you ever look at there
are no gay boating magazines no gay
camping magazines it's not like gay
paintball it's just oh you're looking
for the gay magazines you me will go
through those swinging doors sir
[Laughter]
guy with wedding ring yes you're a
cowboy
enter with pictures of his kids in his
wallet right queer fancy
it's not a thing
guy who looks nervous wearing a mask
still gay week
all right
national homo review my point is they
don't it's not it's just like the gay
thing it's very it's it's a sex it's a
hyper-sexualized culture that's okay
because it's largely men and men like
having sex with things now dr susan
hopkins the chief medical advisor
also uh for the same uh in
uk hsa i'm just going to use that to
abbreviate it it's too long uh wrote the
evidence suggests that there may be
transmission of the monkey pox virus in
the community spread
by close contact now
close contact could be anybody is that
the six feet like covet yeah
that's how you avoid monkey pox with
with a yardstick like a junior high
dance
okay yes
well unless you have a yard stick in
your pants yes then you're gonna touch
monkey but come on their yardsticks are
not in their pants so this is where the
festival comes in as far as how monkey
pox has begun spreading now it's existed
historically
but why now that's the question you
should be asking why now well many
outlets have been sort of quietly
reporting on these outbreaks saying that
it came from a fast like a festival
maybe and the farthest they go is like a
fetish festival yeah here's the thing
it's uh the darklings festival in what's
the name of the place right outside of
uh brussels the name uh uh i forgot the
name of the city it's right out it's
near brooks and here we go antwerp uh
dark lands festival dark lands that's
fitting
and this is what it looks like
the dark holes festival oh geez a second
do you wanna have that do you have the
pictures from the festival there kevin
bring up the pictures by the way token
now just got married so he's on he's on
a honeymoon so we have kevin here do you
have the pictures from the festival he's
visiting the wetlands i don't think they
weren't thank you those weren't all
right guys get us the pictures from the
darkness festival because that really
drives it home no they allow cameras
they really they're looking at the
cameras as they spread monkey pop are
you serious yeah
i'm glad you said spreading monkeys i
raw dogged nine somali pirates at this
festival and all i got was this stupid
pox
[Music]
so here's a description
of the festival camp canine at darklands
is dedicated to pups and their handlers
with a giant ball pit mosh area and
plenty of puppy play equipment on hand
just to be clear there are no actual
dogs
wow i just want to be clear
it might have spread at this festival
yeah where they have ball pits and puppy
play yes without dogs without dogs is
this like the congressman on a leash
it's weird sex stuff gerald it's weird
sex stuff this entire segment is
uncomfortable because i don't know
what's going to get us removed it's
weird sex stuff at a gay festival please
shut up festival please be sure to pick
up after your idiot yes
oh gosh
that requires a cleanup crew that in a
hazmat suit says choose whether you'll
join as a blindfolded mare
bottom or hungry stallion top in
parentheses
a team of stable masters will take care
of the safety of the mayors well seems
someone didn't do their job
that's called horseplay by the way
yeah why would that's what they called
it not me
what'd you what'd you do this weekend uh
somali pirate son i was just horsing
around
just playing
i had a crop riding crop with don lemon
yeah
that is so bad so the media says yeah
it's a festival it's a festival guys get
us those pictures right now so uh
right now guys
hot
how's that is that really a festival
it's not really a festival it's just an
orgy just a ball pit of horses gay men
horses yeah gay men horses dogs and also
the irony and they're like i'm a mare no
you're not you're not at the mayor
you're not a mayor there's it's only
stallions that's the problem
you're just playing
and even using the term stallions is
very generous so there's a 7 to 14 day
incubation picture okay so let's bring
up the pictures that always yeah there
you go oh
well i'm still confused that's just a
music festival right yeah yeah
it's just like who's who well you went
to van's warped tour a couple i did and
you know i always remember leather
showcases yeah i went to oh of course
when i went to bonnaroo and you saw
bands like wien and you know right
and raw dogging nigerian princes of
course i wore only a leather cup yes
it's not even really a cup it's more of
a saucer with a hole in it yes yeah
there's no cup to actually protect from
anything so look here's the thing they
are tripping over themselves the media
right now to say well it looks like it's
spreading the community without it
without saying it's winning in the gay
community right because it's very
important even though statistically this
is something that could be very easily
solved as far as the spread right now
okay because it's not just spread it's
not like the aids thing it's not like
you know where it's primarily spread
through uh homosexual activity which we
know now um
it's that right now it happened to be
spread at an event where people were
having a bunch of gay sex so it could
make its way out
of that sort of incubated petri dish
we can address that pretty quickly we'll
talk about it's called ring vaccination
where basically you can just vaccinate
as opposed to you know quarantining
healthy people
quarantine the sick people vaccinating
the sick people which you can do with
the smallpox vaccine we'll get to that
however we have to balance that
the science
without making people feel bad just
listen to sky news one unusual aspect of
this is that a high proportion of the
cases are gay or bisexual men not at all
and it's important to say that this is
not a disease that's likely to be spread
by sex and it's likely to have nothing
to do with sexuality that's good but
health authorities are trying to raise
awareness
in men that they need to be aware of the
symptoms because it may be
spreading within a sexual network men
who are having sex with other men
who may be at risk simply because
direct and intimate skin to skin contact
could be the straight people have skin
to skin contact trying to raise
awareness
to balance
this could affect anybody but at the
moment they are very concerned about
spreading within the gay and bisexual
community in particular it has to be
balanced with the stigma of accurate
science
uh do tell uh why is it that uh the gay
sexual context seems to spread it more
it's not so much it's not so listen
careful with the stigma
it's not so much the gay sex as it is
the volume of sexual activity with gay
men
having sex with lots of men think of it
this way look removal moral barriers
right you're a straight man i want you
to i want you to think about about this
for a second think of every attractive
woman who you thought if you weren't
married if you weren't faithful remember
moral barriers okay for a moment
every attractive woman that you've ever
wanted to have sex with right now
for a gay man that's every other man
and with attractive straight women
right you want to have sex with her but
she's saying no no no no maybe for gay
men it's yes yes yes all at the same
time
that's why it spreads so fast oh oh
pay it forward yeah according to this
charge with no condom
it's doo doo and bleeding this so i
primarily spritz now belgium has
recorded its fourth case of monkey pox
all four cases have been linked to the
darklings festival yeah by the way the
political article that was covering
specifically that was saying uh this
this festival gathering in may right
they didn't even say fetish festival or
anything we don't want to stigmatize it
right back like back when oprah said
based on fouchy's intel that one in five
heterosexual couples would uh would have
been affected by sexuals would die of
aids oh man i was soft-peddling it you
were both of them were in there said
they were gonna
yeah
basically she said one in five are gonna
die yeah that's the quote that we found
wow and i said but look under your seat
you all have prep pills
open season which by the way i have to
tell you in looking up this monkey pock
stuff i went down a really dark rabbit
hole in the internet yeah yes of all
these gay blogs talking about monkey pox
so when they were talking about and
saying
with the prep pill it's been sex in new
york city for a gay man like 1979 before
the aids epidemic but now i have to be
worried about intestinal parasites and
monkey pox and we're just going ah
yeah me too i think i have carpal tunnel
now yes
and a screen that's not as clear as it
once was oh no laptop's broken um
portugal has recorded at least 21
confirmed cases okay
and some of those link portugal to
belgium star clans festival
all right spain also has 21 confirmed
cases
most of them linked to a gay sauna
and i guess fauci has a new job known as
a sauna yeah
but she has a new part-time job i guess
is that yeah
then did we get that no
again we're short staffed today
i'm doing research
again in gay saunas really
oh yes there's a new gay bug i'm going
to hurry up and now
yeah
oh yeah all the cover i need oh goody
oh boy you guys are going to be a bunch
of white flags 20 years from now
you're sitting down with this notepad
like what are you and i like to watch
yeah
i'm a voyeur of your dying show me how
you get it again i didn't see it the
first time yes i didn't see it the first
time just ignore me in the corner oh
i've just turned into a towel wreck wait
wait wait are you the mayor or the
stallion i confuse the two it's sort of
like you know ac dc but they're both dc
they're both ac
how i don't understand how this
functions and it's like well let us show
you he's like i'm very curious so did
you bring a cooler in here yes it's bad
sandwiches would you like one yeah
a tuna on rye
got smoked salmon and capers oh
boy now we have other countries that are
experiencing outbreaks okay the uk 21 to
30 cases america one to five cases
canada one to five 11 to 20 suspected
one came through montreal who allegedly
also was at the darklings festival
here's the thing it's not necessarily
gay sex unlike aids hiv which is almost
entirely gay sex or intravenous drug use
it's that it seems to have spread where
the gay behavior was prevalent one
person was at this festival who came
from one of those countries where they
and by one of those countries i mean
craphole countries where this actually
still exists and it's rampant and then
probably had sex with like i don't know
40 guys at the festival and that's how
it spread just taking a wild guess i'm
ball parking it was a three-day festival
you do the math i mean that's likely
yeah i think ballparking was the problem
yes exactly
ball popping is the term that you use
yes
a five-day festival was a five-day
festival gotta go up oh for crying out
loud
why do you need five days of that yeah
especially when you consider the
refractory periods it's just
that's just bad and it's spreading
everywhere like a
virus it's hard to tell somebody that
you know something hurts when all you
can do is bark
we shouldn't have made our safe word
woof
[Laughter]
so what is monkey pox to give you
something
oh yeah the only thing you can eat is
carrots nobody's eating them
so what is monkey box well okay it's a
zoonotic disease um endemic to western
central africa
the same family of smallpox much less
severe than smallpox to be clear so
people who are trying you know trying to
scare you right now the strain uh that
we currently know about it has a
mortality rate of less than one percent
but we all know how the left feels about
things that are less than one percent
likely to kill you
not it's gonna say what it is yeah
destroy your lives yeah lock down the
entire planet right
well thankfully the other one has a
mortality rate up to about ten percent
the other strain so the monkey fox yeah
the monkey pucks there's so the two
different i guess they call it clouds or
whatever it is so well here's the thing
okay we got lucky on this one you have
the the former vice president joe biden
saying one thing and then the cdc saying
well you really shouldn't be concerned
right it's tough to know who to believe
now
one point there was some killer this
looks like it's spread from a gay
festival but they're saying but it's not
necessarily spread through that method
of contact because what we could be
dealing with to be clear is we could be
dealing with a mutated form of this
virus now that's why it's pretty hard to
trust them because if this is perhaps i
don't know like in some hypothetical
hypothetical scenario a weaponized
mutation of the virus to make it more
transmissible
to make it more deadly then it's
difficult to take anything that's being
said right now at face value the truth
is monkey pox is not aerosol it's not
like coveted in that same way that's why
they were saying that you shouldn't be
nearly as worried it's primarily
transmitted from skin to skin contact
lesions
which again still begs the question why
is it still like you know skin lesions i
mean you know
strain people too
it's the volume it's the it's the number
yeah but this is precisely the problem
that we have with not being able to
trust our institutions because now
they've lied to us we know that they
were wrong how about i just say it that
way about certain things within coveted
so now i thought you're gonna say aids
no no well that too i'm gonna go i'm
gonna go something more recent ebola
right yeah exactly so now we don't trust
them so if monkey pox was a true threat
you're screwed because people are like
nah you've been saying this guy is
falling for too long now and it's not
right right and now that we know that
it's probably not they shouldn't be out
well it's also not new so there's a 2003
outbreak of monkey pox 47 confirmed
cases or probable cases according to the
cdc this was in 2003 um and it was the
first time that monkey pox was reported
outside of africa it was here good for
us get a trophy for the first place well
you know it's a mult it's a it's it
we're importing ah yes nice because to
appreciate to appropriate us to
appreciate which by the way june is
cultural appropriation month i forgot i
cannot wait send in your favorite you
know comment below send in your favorite
uh your countries that you want to see
this year i completely forgot about
culture it always sneaks up banned from
youtube month yes
[Laughter]
now this came from infected rodents from
ghana and uh all of the confirmed cases
back in 2003 were from contact with
prairie dogs that were bought as pets
don't do that who's buying prairie dogs
as pets this is even before the show oh
my god
it's like this journal's just not doing
it anymore let's go prairie dog give me
that big one it took them like years to
figure out is it coming from the prairie
dog or the empty toilet paper roll
filled with dryer sheets we don't know
now in 2021 uh there was one case in
texas man again returning from nigeria
in 2021 maryland had one traveler also
returning from nigeria but uh right now
no one has died from it so again how
does it spread do we need vaccines just
so you guys unders as opposed to fear
porn there's been a push again now that
you're seeing from people who are
uninformed to what to what to what to
mask up let me read you a quote from the
new york city health department cdc
masks can protect against monkey pox as
well as other viruses circulating in new
york city such as covid19 well there you
go i mean come on it's not so much about
the monkey pox you're just
i mean oh if you put this pitching it on
your legion riddled penis yes
even then it's too porous you're telling
me
you're doing a puppet show
oh what's scarier again it's not aerosol
it's not aerosol eyes like cove but even
though they told us that it wasn't and
they said that it was and they said it
wasn't and they said that it was why
don't you trust your institutions bodily
fluids lesions you know touching the
lesions skin on skin contact it's not
nearly as contagious now here's
something else people are talking about
large scale vaccinations you saw they
just purchased and they're stockpiling
vaccinations a smallpox vaccine here's
the thing we don't need large-scale
vaccinations it's a very very silly idea
i know we don't want to stigmatize
people
but
what you do with something like this is
called ring vaccination that's the
current standard of care again we're
talking about science and what does ring
vaccination means uh what does that mean
that means the close contacts of people
who've been infected with monkey pox
right you vaccinate them and you cut off
any routes of transmission look let's be
honest what could have happened is this
started in belgium this
puppy
mayor bear stallion weird gay sex orgy
okay that took place for five days
quarantine all those people all the
people that could have possibly had sex
with case closed done but we don't want
to stigmatize
we should definitely stick with dice
oh my gosh this this isn't a problem the
problem is joe biden going out and
saying everybody should be concerned
about this because people have we're all
still a little bit nervous from what
just happened and it's not that we'll
necessarily get sick and die it's that
our government is going to do something
stupid in the world again we just went
through that nobody wants to go back of
course he was concerned hunter was at
the festival
to be fair though he wasn't taking he
was just dealing that's true well he
lost five laptops at this festival
though so lots of great information
coming out soon
and he also filled them up with all of
the information while there you have
like a frequent buyer's program with
laptops he's like i'm back for another
one geez i just keep dropping them
everywhere just uses his monkey pox
platinum card some stupid stallion stole
it for me i get points i get points for
every lesion so look according to
bernard took it yeah
courtney just kept saying woof but he
looks terrified
there's a guy who kept following him so
according to health officials
little barrels under its neck you're
like this isn't water
you just open up your he says a letter
for help he just opens just a picture of
that saint bernard with that guy he
didn't help me at all
that's you
just a self-portrait like a lot at least
the music's terrible yeah
no better way to spread monkey pox than
gay orgy in house
are you up there is that is that moby
dressed like a doc a dachshund
all right
according to health officials you can
relax a little bit some of them now so
it goes against what biden said here you
go there's no need to panic here this is
not going to spread looks like he was at
the festival into
the general
population and cause an epidemic like
coronavirus has now just to be clear
just because he looks like his immune
system is falling out of the rest of his
body does not mean that he is not an
authoritative source so how do you avoid
monkey pox it's pretty clear uh just so
again i want to help you
don't go to gay orgies uh
uh you know get bitten by rodents
or get a prairie dog as a pet
that's it that's it you probably won't
get monkey pox there you go well that's
impossible just you know stay away from
her that's always great tell me not to
breathe yes
tell a sparrow not to sing
tell an eagle not to be majestic yes
good luck
but put a monkey pox riddled golden
doodle by any other name still be as
riddled that's right oh
god
i just i'm so just i'm so disgusting
antwerp in may stay away from antwerp is
there gonna be another flood soon enough
do we think i mean i think it's fire and
brimstone
that's right we're due does uh they sort
of he sort of staggers them don't you
[Laughter]
there's a man wearing a dog collar not
bleed the same as you i mean imagine
them writing about that in the old
testament different places sure but it's
like lord what if i find 10 good men uh
you're gonna need a little bit more than
that considering that they're wearing
chokers and having sex to enya for five
days
give me a little more than ten good men
you know what i'm just gonna turn the
whole city into salt it's going to look
like superman's dad's bachelor pad how
about that
this guy's wearing horseshoes and a
light up unicorn hat yeah
lord this doesn't seem that bad right
now trust me in a couple thousand years
you'll understand right you know what i
hate sticky shoes yeah i really do yeah
your shoes would be ruined after an
event like that yeah it'd be like
walking through a dollar cineplex yeah
this is the worst
they step in gum kind of like it's just
sort of oh
like what is it what are they just this
is coat the floor and juji fruit
i just bought these
it's like hold on a second before i move
on to taiwan uh right oh right now you
have joe biden they were just talking
about taiwan on cnn we want to talk but
right now he's saying a recession the
u.s is not inevitable uh sorry he
mispronounced uh is happening but let's
hear him uh he means middle of nowhere
well let's hear what they have to say
about the recession certainly that we
have problems the u.s economy is not bad
right now it's growing famine is low but
the risk of recession is elevated and as
the federal reserve so guys don't lose
hope
it's just elevated but the economy is
not bad
trust your institutions
and it knocks the us economy into david
lynch a thundercat and a serial killer
all have good news for you 2023 and
certainly a lot of uh businesses i
thought that was pretty crack aaron
sorkin expecting it it is a um a fraught
situation because uh you've gotten the
positive benefits you want in terms of
growth that's just him on adderall and a
typewriter
and the fed has uh decided that it's
going to do something about it he hasn't
blinked oh thank god the fed has decided
they're going to do something about it
don't forget to wet eyelids in an
exclusive by the way and i know we're
not covering the economy right now
because it's so terrible but they're
basically spinning all weekend long
every show that i watched was well
unemployment is low and you know the job
numbers are looking better we're adding
a lot of jobs and uh the economy is not
so bad it's growing and i'm like
yeah we haven't added one job since our
peak in 2019 just to be clear there's
more part-time jobs the wages aren't
very good for these jobs and they're
worth even less because of inflation and
you have uh far fewer people in the
labor force participation market so this
is what this is how they lie about those
numbers because and we've gone through
this several times but this is what
happens they blame us for sowing
distrust right they blame you
for showing distrust when you say hold
on a second
i feel like uh i don't know i got a
ballot to my old house that i didn't
request and anyone could do anything
wrong with that they say hey a second
don't so distrust in your institutions
when they say hey the economy is fine he
said i don't feel like it's fine don't
don't don't so distrust you know what
so's distrust them saying you know we
probably won't have a recession the
economy is doing relatively well and you
are driving past if you're in california
six seven dollar gas right here in texas
close to five dollar gas if you're
paying twice as much for your food
if you're if you know friends who are
unemployed you know that people are
having to to tighten their belt buckles
right now or because they can't afford
anything you know what you're living
through skyrocketing costs inflation
you're looking at your 401k you're
looking at your retirement savings it's
worse than it's been in the last 10
years
and they're saying so don't worry you
know the economy is actually doing well
they're so unaccountable they don't even
understand
that it would just be better if they
said
things aren't great but here's how we
think they can improve but they're so
confident that no one will call them on
their lies they say the economy is
actually doing pretty well that's what
they just said yeah
that's basically what i heard all
weekend they're like oh we added 500 000
jobs i'm like yeah and people have to
work two of them so that they can make
ends meet thank you and by the way this
is also another myth that you see people
uh people out there touting they go well
and if you look at the price of
of gas it's
you know the president doesn't really
control it it's a global problem hold on
a couple of things first off if you look
at some of the economic indexes the
united states is doing worse than many
other countries okay not all but it's
doing worse than a lot of other
countries second do you understand that
being the world's only global superpower
in 2022 is if we create the problem it
will affect the rest of the world
it's not a problem that originated in
sweden
in other words of course if we decide
that we're going to create total
a total upheaval right with russia and
the ukraine and send 40 billion here and
and make sure that some of these right
now we're looking at a wheat by the way
a wheat uh supply chain issue just so
you know the united states should not be
affected by that but we will because
we'll export our wheat even though we
don't need to this is what happens is
the united states creates a problem just
because it's happening elsewhere in the
world does not mean that the most
powerful man in the free world and the
most powerful country who sets
international policy for the free will
is not responsible for it
you can't have it both ways and say well
donald trump is not the reason that we
had record low guess look record low gas
when adjusted for inflation versus
record high record low unemployment
and record high wage growth
period when you look at average average
individual earnings versus the worst and
here's the thing we had eight years of
this
this is a really hard job for the media
we had eight years of this with barack
obama now we have the former vice
president so we had eight three i don't
count that last year because of covet we
had eight three we're going to have
another four we will never
probably in another generation or two
have this kind of a clear contrast and
despite all the wokeness despite what
all the democrats want to tell you when
they go out and protest dave chappelle a
lot of people when they go into that
voting booth they say you know what my
life is definitely worse off and they
pull that lever and what's going to
happen the media is going to blame us
the media is going to blame you for
sowing distrust and never take
accountability themselves they're like
the amber herd of the public sphere
right or the media and joe biden is
going to gin up the monkey pox fear and
say well we we should probably just send
out ballots to everybody so that they
don't have gay sex in line and get
monkey pox right while they're waiting
to vote yes
yeah i mean it's unavoidable yeah really
you can't abstinence only is not you
have a prevention strategy is more
sensible yes
i voted in a restroom yes yes freeway
saunas have voting booths too right they
do yeah yeah not digital voting booths i
mean that just becomes an incredible
electrical hazard
it's a hole punch but there's a giant
hole
so now speaking of more economic
upheaval and turmoil look i've been very
clear about this and we're going to go
to mug club later and gerald and uh
ginger snap are going to have a healthy
debate yeah uh i've said that we
shouldn't be involved in ukraine because
we do need to you know save our keep our
power drive for taiwan i do think that
taiwan is an important stronghold and if
you look at what china wants to do with
taiwan and how that would disrupt the
global supply chain
i mean china going after taiwan
would probably be the actual catalyst
for what would be closest to what we
recognize as world war three yeah
and uh so i think it's pretty important
now that being said
considering the importance of it it
would seem that a unified consistent
message that is simply
decipherable
to human beings
would be important
so former vice president joe biden
speaking in tokyo next to the uh prime
minister of japan uh fumio kishida
he addressed the question of how the u.s
would respond if china invaded taiwan
he's the first president
to say this but part of what he says
contradicts the second part of what he
says
you didn't want to get involved in the
ukraine conflict militarily for obvious
reasons are you willing to get involved
militarily to defend taiwan if it comes
to that yes
you are first president to say that
that's the commitment we made
well that's incorrect we made we are not
look here's the situation
we agree with one china policy
then you can't
defend agreements made from there
but the idea that
that it can be taken by force
just taken by force is just not it's
just not appropriate to dislocate the
entire region
and be another action similar to what
happened in
in uh in ukraine
and so it's a it's a burden that is even
stronger that is a big ear piece what
he's wearing beats by dre
he signed a new sponsorship deal with
them so a couple of things
the statement breaks with decades of the
united states policy right on taiwan uh
that being said he said yes we would
intervene militarily okay so that's this
statement then he says we recognize
china's one china policy ah
those two are the opposite
it might be foreign to you would be the
exact equivalent they said so joe biden
do you consider yourself a democrat of
course
and uh i will continue uh as a
republican you know what uh a fight for
conservatism i don't understand this
the two cannot be the two you can't
reconcile the two together and this is
the beauty of just saying things that
don't make sense because then there's no
accountability and you can respond with
when they say hey you said that you
would intervene militarily no i did i
said i would recognize china's one one
china policy so yeah you said that one
phrase later but yeah well which phrase
but that's the phrase that i meant more
and the next person says hold on a
second are you actually recognizing
china's one one one china politics it's
like well no we're going to defend
taiwan military but you just said yeah
but i but i said this before that
how how how do we call you on your
[ __ ] joe you can't well he even he
even gave it away he said you would end
up with a situation like ukraine exactly
that is why we warned you when this
happened with ukraine that china was
paying attention and now you're in this
untenable position of saying we will
defend
but it's also part of china and here's
the thing what he's saying
doesn't make
any it also cannot be reconciled with
what the u.s state department they just
removed key sections from the u.s taiwan
relations page look let me read it for
you they removed the sections that read
the united states recognized the
government of the people's republic of
china as the sole legal government of
china removed that's removed the united
states does not support taiwan
independence that's removed i think that
now see i think that would be a good
thing because taiwan should be its own
country great i think we should
recognize taiwan's independence i think
it's important and he said that until he
said the exact opposite of that and then
i wanted to punch my own face repeatedly
yeah for a half a second i was like well
good oh
so crap by the way october of last year
this isn't the first time he's done this
no very similar comments october of last
year i have had i've spoken and spent
more time with xi jinping than any other
world leader has
that's why you have winnie the pooh you
know you hear people saying biden wants
to start a new cold war with china i
don't want a cold war with china i just
want to make china understand that we
are not going to step back we are not
going to change any of our views so are
you saying that the united states would
come to taiwan's defense is trying to
attack yes we have a commitment i know
he said the same thing i spent a lot of
time with him i like him he's good and
then so you defend taiwan uh
yeah
i don't unders
look there are two stances i seriously
can't follow it no there are two stances
you recognize taiwan's independence that
it's not china that these people have a
right to be free from
the communist thumb of china okay
or you support china's one china policy
you support this idea that taiwan cannot
be an independent state it's one or the
other and he consistently says both
things so does the state department now
let me be clear what the official stance
has been because i wanted to give him
props and say good for you me too good
for you for having the balls to say you
know what we will go and defend our
friends
in taiwan yeah just because i want to
watch you know john cena make another
stutter step
so let me give you some history here um
this is uh uh you know switching when we
switch sort of our our attack i guess um
1978 the us has practiced what is known
as strategic ambiguity with taiwan and
that's no promise to defend that's no
promise not to defend
and most people assume that this meant
the united states was defend but we kept
them on their toes
what am i it's like a no-look jab right
like i don't know boom boom i don't know
i don't know what are you doing
boom boom boom that's what it is in 1978
we had a few bigger fish to fry right
yes they're still in the midst of the
cold war and so we don't want to really
set things off in two places right get
it it makes some sense at the time right
well you don't think that that's what it
should be anymore
oh i i think decades ago it should have
changed where are we especially
descendants and i are going to talk
about yeah because basically what it
does is it tells china like okay we're
not encouraging taiwan to separate from
you guys so it kind of placates them
lets them say face and then taiwan it
basically tells them like hey we may or
may not come to your aid so don't go and
declare independence thinking that
you've got your big brother over here
ready to come in and get your back and
so it keeps both parties kind of at bay
for a while but all it does is kick the
can down the road eventually this is
going to be a thing well and if you also
understand the mission statement of
china and by the way uh the communist
chinese party it's very racist they
believe in basically one superior race
of people the chinese race and they
believe in the sort of you know pan
pacific and this is by the way this goes
back a long if you look at the wars and
the battles between china and the
japanese and also hilariously enough if
you look at world war ii the japanese
believe that they were the superior race
and so did the aryans and they teamed up
and i mean one of them has to be wrong
would have been an awkward fight at the
end of that war if they won yeah both
were wrong thank god so far i guess we
beat the allies how do you want to
handle this that's you're superior and
we are too okay
let's just know let's settle it with the
game of who can reach the the top shelf
oh they're superior okay another
genocide oh you voila tricks i know it's
okay that's not who makes the best
sauerkraut yes oh it's us
we win again
so here's the thing uh the white house
is already walking it back yeah
i think this is from this morning
couldn't do it fast enough this is what
it says as the president said uh for
those confused referring to the former
vice president joe biden as the
president said our policy has not
changed but he also said that it did he
reiterated our one china policy and our
commitment to peace and stability across
the taiwan strait ah he also reiterated
our commitment under the taiwan
relations act to provide taiwan with the
military means to defend itself
no no he didn't he said that the united
states would intervene militarily yes
which is actually more aggressive than
what we've done with the ukraine which
is you know we haven't intervened
militarily we've just spotted billions
and billions and billions and billions
and billions and billions of dollars to
aid how could that possibly piss off
russia are them seen as the united
states in an act of war
proxy war they were just asking if his
diaper was full into his earpiece and he
replied yes it was a total mistake the
distortion there's too much bass on the
beats by dr dre
there it is yes
they smell toast
he said yes are you tasting wet pennies
yes yes yes we completely always aren't
bad
so here's the thing now they're trying
to say the white house is saying he did
he said this but he also said this
what they're trying to say is we want to
be friends with china we don't want to
piss them off and uh we also want to act
like we'll uh protect taiwan but we
probably won't this is also important
because here's a here's another layer to
this
biden's uh he just he just signed uh
this new indo-pacific it's an echo it's
a trade agreement it's called the
indo-pacific economic framework okay
let's bring this up it's from abc news
and this has 13 members for trading okay
let me read you some of them let me read
you the japan south korea thailand
thailand i was about to say vietnam
vietnam thailand australia new zealand
hmm so you see it's like by the way it's
very asiatic
there we go one country seems to be
missing
[Music]
any idea which one gerald
could it be taiwan great guess oh boom
they don't recognize it as a country
that's weird and taiwan is obviously
being excluded at the behest of china
just to be clear just like when the who
was interviewed by on a skype call and
they were asked about taiwan they
refused to even acknowledge them there
this is the difference between donald
trump yeah
donald trump and this guy this guy is
beholden to china in a way that donald
trump wasn't yeah
this guy he just said he spent more time
with winnie the pooh than anybody else
they have a great relationship
that's what was one of his major selling
points is i'm not gonna i'm gonna
re-establish respect across the world
look this is also important to know this
is tigger yeah
let's anyway let's we'll go back to the
monkey party man his friend yeah yes yes
this is the monkey pox thing we moved on
from monkey pox so um
this is one of those issues where
it's really hard for people to
understand that's by design
he says nothing by saying all of the
things
that's the strategy it really is it's
say everything take every position and
then afterwards claim credit as though
you were right let me just sort of uh
make the case to you why it's different
from ukraine you know uh
taiwan we're very very dependent on a
place like taiwan for uh computer chips
a lot of people don't realize there are
certain things that come from taiwan you
know technological uh innovations that
come out of there certainly
technological manufacturing uh that
comes out of taiwan not not china and
that's why china wants control of that
if china gets control of the chipsets
you know
uh that exist in taiwan and they somehow
managed to get control of taiwan we did
a whole segment on this you know this is
what this war would look like it would
have to take place during one of two
months uh
out of the entire year because of the
the seas and how they act how they would
have to conquer the land how they would
have to be thwarted what kind of uh of
ship care of uh carriers they would need
we did a whole segment on that we'll
actually put a link in the description
um and all references are available at
lightweight.com i don't want to get into
that but the the issue here is this is
something that would affect us very
in a very serious way now i know many of
you are saying well that's the case with
ukraine it didn't have to be though
we are dependent on ukraine for nothing
so that's the problem here for example
with ukraine let's look at that the
wheat shortage yeah you know the united
states is the bread basket of the world
right we we do not need
any wheat from ukraine i think they
supply something like 70 80 depending
which number you use of the world's
wheat
when you're a country the size of a
thimble
and your entire
your entire economic you know your
export plan is wheat right this is a
problem you have places like china you
have places across
all of asia uh
and europe that say okay we don't want
our economy to be based on wheat this is
this is labor intensive let's just do
manufacturing and we'll get our wheat
from ukraine well guess what this is
really going to hurt a lot of countries
particularly countries in the third
world who are dependent on wheat from
ukraine now
america first would be
sorry guys
we have our own wheat though we're gonna
make sure that we can feed americans
first
but you can bet what's going to happen
is oh the world has a wheat shortage so
america is going to go in and help hey i
i have an idea how about they come in
and help us
when does that ever happen we get to
hear sweden [ __ ] about america and ah
you guys are warmongers right and then
now they want to join nato decades later
because they realize the official policy
line of being a perpetual [ __ ] doesn't
work in the real world hey how about you
guys come help us hey how about west
african nations hey how about you send
us some stuff for free
hey haiti where's our disaster relief
no no how about this in other words
instead of that we're not going to
expect any help from you whether it be
militarily whether it be in emergency
services we're just not going to give
you our stuff when we need it
the problem with that mind you have
stephen colbert saying i don't mind
paying a few bucks more for gas well
guess what if you have a family of five
15 a gallon oh yes right fifteen dollars
a year yeah fifteen bucks more for gas
guess what americans shouldn't have to
make that choice
but what about these people
sorry don't care
don't care
just because we are more successful just
because we have more bounty does not
mean that we should be required to give
it to the rest of the world and so i'm
not a non-interventionist
i just don't believe that we should be
in foreign conflicts unless it benefits
us that's what america first is and
defending taiwan is very important
because if china gets control of taiwan
boom it's a skip and a hop and you look
through the islands japan and then of
course they have this unholy alliance
with north korea this is far more
serious than russia ukraine that's why
they don't want to be clear on it
because of how much of a failure it's
been
with russia ukraine for crying out loud
how many billions of dollars how many
billions of dollars now with ukraine are
we talking about 80 billion dollars i
don't know what the total is it was 40
billion it was 10 billion 40 billion
there was a 7 billion i don't know well
they were trying to get there quickly
with the 40 billion too many billions 40
yeah so well you can't do that now we're
40 at first right issues here yeah no we
we've given so much money and so many
people have made the point like we
really don't have the money to give guys
just printing money at this point and
then wondering why inflation's happening
right
seriously asking those questions in the
same sentence it's it's it is absolutely
this administration's policy to ask
questions or make statements that
contradict themselves or answer the
question in the question it's like yeah
i just printed a bunch of money but
there's inflation it's super weird we
have no idea what to do okay you know
what this is a genuine experiment by the
way you can hit the like button or share
a button on youtube but i do want you
guys to comment below
genuine question
all the references are available at
lighthousecredit.com so i want you to
read them i want you to go watch the
original videos don't take my word for
it
i will tell you i'm not lying but i ask
that you assume i am
uh
let's say something happened between
china and taiwan a conflict erupted okay
hypothetical tomorrow
what will this administration do
do you have an answer
guys get out of this question but that
is an honest question honestly what will
they do do you know do you know what
they i have no idea if china owns our
debt and we're giving taiwan fake money
that we don't even have how does this
even work like we're technically china's
really just
paying taiwan through us
technically that's big money i'm not an
economist but that sounds correct is
that right i mean the china doesn't own
all of our debts no no no not all of our
debt but some of it yeah they have a
large stake yes i just uh someday would
just like uh you know remember that debt
no no can we just be like we didn't we
don't have that debt because we bought
we
we said to a place that doesn't exist
yeah what is going to happen exactly
it's right off your coast you should go
look and see if you can just memory what
are they going to do break our thumbs so
maybe we should let them destroy taiwan
and be all like yeah man
we didn't even know where your money
went that place didn't happen so weird
yeah it'll be a weird no but it's a
genuine question does anyone know what
this administration would do i have no
idea that's what i mean though do you
know what they would do
based on what joe biden comment below
based on what he has said and based on
what the white house has said okay china
invades taiwan
it would have to take place i believe
during uh uh either october or april or
is it october i believe it's october
april those are the only two months that
they could even try and brave
so um china invades taiwan let's say
that that happens they start a war
based on what joe biden has said and the
white house and the state department
does the united states intervene
or not
i'm not asking what you want i'm asking
are you clear
on what the answer would be
no i mean i think there's no definitive
answer right now what they will do is
whatever is politically expedient at
whatever cost danger to win the election
or to win favor with the american people
they will do it just like they're doing
in ukraine right now because they think
there's enough support do you see the
problem do you see the problem here's
problem no here's the problem is we
should have never had anything to do
with ukraine and russia there's going to
be foreign war fatigue and like we
always talked about we should have kept
our powder dry for taiwan and by the
time it gets to something that actually
affects us on a significant level and
someone who is a significant ally taiwan
who we've been [ __ ] around for
decades by the way and have not been
clear we haven't defined the
relationship people will have fatigue of
foreign intervention and then say you
know what we did with the ukraine so no
taiwan and they're left holding the bag
because this administration will only do
what is politically expedient not make
the hard decisions the hard decision
should have been sorry ukraine
that's not our war
that would have been the hard decision
they said oh you know what right now
people feel bad we need something to
move on because
uh ukraine people are not really happy
about all this aid going over the
ukraine despite what the media tells you
ukraine sir i keep saying i said the
ukraine it's ukraine now
there's going to be war fatigue when it
comes to taiwan and china and that is an
important one that is one that i have
said for a very long time the united
states would need to be involved with if
we want the world to remain as it is or
to avoid world war iii but when you
don't have principles when you don't
have any kind of a backbone you cannot
provide a consistent answer you simply
end up going whichever way the wind
blows and that's how you end up with
this think of it's not just a consistent
policy that has led to the inflation gas
prices it's the remarkably inconsistent
policy
it's not a consistent policy that has
read
led to businesses being shut down it's
the inconsistent policy it's not knowing
where we're go it's not knowing where
we're going saying oh okay we're going
to reopen okay good no no lockdown okay
i'm sorry
lockdown you can't make decisions based
on that whether you liked donald trump
or hated him you knew which direction
that ship you knew which direction that
was headed and if he didn't shut up he
was going to turn that car right back
around
i cannot answer this this is what i do
for a living i cannot answer to you what
will happen if there's some kind of an
invasion of taiwan on china's behalf
i cannot answer to you what will happen
based on what this administration is
sending out
and no expert can any talking heads
right now on cnn are lying no one has
any clue all i can tell you is that it
will be based on political expediency
and we know that americans have very
short memories that's what they're
banking on that's a horrible place to be
and historically it is not a way
to create foreign policy so we're
actually going to argue about this and i
guess watch the new mission impossible
trailer oh there's another one well
we're going to argue about monkey pox in
a way that we could absolutely not
discuss on youtube i bet cruz is going
to be running in this trailer yeah okay
over under if he's running
i'd be willing to bet significant money
that's all he does is right i'm looking
forward to another vietnam and gas
shortage yes
well also don't forget the gas lines
yeah not just the shortage gas lines
speeding limit at 50 miles an hour or
under yeah yeah i'm excited we're headed
the right direction and by that i mean
um i may go to mug club or i may go
swallow a sword youtube piss off
[Music]
you